Is. I love adult money.
I just got these on eBay.
I'm literally.
I'm not kidding.
I'm pulling up to the club with this bag.
No one can say anything to me.
This lip gloss is from 2014,
and we will be trying it on.
Oh, my god.
This is crazy.
let me put my lip liner on.
This is my literal go to lip stain.
Um, game changer, honestly.
Now for the moment of truth.
We're putting on the through the dark one direction lip gloss from.
Haha,
it's broken. Oh, no,
it's broken. That's crazy.
Oh, no.
Through the dark reveal.
Are you freaking serious?
You need to get one of those, like,
Sephora samples,
like, the. Let me handle this.
Okay,
it's fine. We're using the orange gloss,
which is kiss you,
and I'm gonna just steal that.
Okay, it's fine.
There's. There's a top to this one.
I don't even care.
I'm putting it in this.
Figure out an issue.
I'll figure out how to deal with the origin later.
Part 2. Trying to lip gloss.
It broke the other one.
What the fuck?
What is going on?
I don't know how I ended up here.
This is 100% what I get.
You know what?
Let's just try the gloss.
And the thing is,
it looks phenomenal.
That is the most messed up part.
Yeah, I'm using my finger. Liz,
it looks so good.
I need to figure out what to Do now.
Wait, that's what I'm saying.
Okay, 1D,
which one is this?
The pink one. But which?
Through the dark?
I think through the dark.
Yeah. Work.
Sign me up.
Can you get me another one? Or is it girl? Yeah,
hopefully the other ones functional.
EWW. Girl,
what am I gonna do with all those lip gloss?
It's all over my hands.
It is a little gritty, though.
Like, you could feel the sparkles.
Yeah, you could feel the sparkles.
We weren't expecting any kind of
phenomenal quality lip gloss from the boys,
but this is cute and I will wear it.
I just have to figure out the whole applicator issue, because right now,
the scene on my bed.
You don't wanna know.
So I had gotten the little,
well, nub out, and it's, like, broken,
I guess, like maybe the glue.
And this is literally a ten year old lip gloss,
so I'll give him some Grace.
Um, I took out the stopper,
so I think the.
What I'm gonna have to do is just like.
Now it's not gonna work.
That's not gonna work.
I will figure something out.
My little sister's trying some.
This
is without lip liner.
Honestly, it still looks good. Yeah.
Oh,
you're embarrassing me.
You're embarrassing me.
Hey, let's cut the tapes.
Okay, guys,
let's cut the tapes.
Hey, guys,
uh, I'm back.
How do I look? Anyway,
my review is like a solid 3.4. Whoa.
Out of five. Okay.
Out of five. Out of five.
Girl don't play.
Color. Definitely there.
It's giving Claire's circa 2,012. Maybe,
um, 2014.
Okay. They were behind.
They were behind.
They were behind. Claire's.
No, no,
you're right, you're right,
you're right. Uh,
the sparkles. Hmm.
Very textured.
It's, like, gritty.
I feel like I have crumbs.
Like, also,
I don't know, I personally,
I think it's a little bright for me.
I wouldn't be able to wear it without lip liner.
Oh.
I also, I'm Tanner than you,
and I look white in this lighting,
so what are you trying to say? Um,
okay.
Anyways, I don't care.
I will be thinking out a way to use this,
but right now,
a little unusable.